[Music]
it's morphin time at least it is for
Final Fantasy 15 magitek exosuits as
they've been delayed in order for Square
Enix to implement a redesign why because
they make 15 protagonists look a little
too much like another group of
crime-fighting teens I'm Matt and this
is your totally unique gamespot news
update the magitek exosuits were a part
of the dlc booster pack that was set for
release on februari 21st it isn't known
exactly what they do for the player
other than provide an advantage in
battle but it's ever so clear what they
look like the four suits resemble Power
Rangers especially the ones from the
upcoming movie Square Enix said that the
company behind Power Rangers got in
touch and pointed out how much the
designs resemble one another as a result
the exosuits are getting a new coat of
paint Final Fantasy 15 s booster pack
plus on the other hand is still
scheduled for release on februari 21st
and it's joined by an update that
increases the level cap furthermore you
can expect a new dlc episodes starring
Claudio and improvements to chapter 13
in March for all your final fantasy and
video game news stay tuned to gamespot